this path is steep and slippery and a
little bit dangerous so excuse me if i
seem a bit distracted i'm trying to
concentrate on balancing the camera
balancing me and saying words this isn't
going to be an in-depth video about
geology i'm not a geologist but today
i'm on the road and my root has taken me
past something that i've wanted to put
my own two feet on for a long time
this is sicker point about an hour east
of edinburgh in scotland
and yeah it just looks like some rocks
on the coast but this is one of the most
important geological sites in the world
and what i love about this story here is
that it combines something that happened
a long time ago more than 200 years
with something that happened a long time
ago hundreds of millions of years
in 1788 james hutton who's now known as
the father of modern geology visited
here in a boat he was looking for places
that would help his theory that the
earth was far far older than people
thought at the time he was looking for
two types of rock right next to each
other in a way that could only have been
made over what we now call geological
time
million years ago a type of grey
sandstone called grey wacky was laid
down at the bottom of what was then the
ocean over millions of years it was
folded tilted and uplifted millimeter by
millimeter until the layers became
almost vertical and then 370 million
years ago red sandstone was laid down on
top of it and over the hundreds of
millions of years that followed as
animals crawled out of the ocean and
dinosaurs evolved and went extinct and
eventually humans came along there was
more uplift more tilting more erosion
and now today above sea level you have
something that should have been
impossible according to scholars in the
18th century two completely different
ages types and directions of rock
locked to each other clear for the eye
to see it's called an unconformity
hutton had found other unconformities
before and he'd find more afterwards
they're not too rare if you know what
you're looking for and he knew what he
was looking for but this was the most
obvious the most dramatic the most
convincing not that it did convince
everyone
opinions don't change that quickly and
the scientific process is slow it took
more than one person and more than one
lifetime for the theory to become
properly accepted
but now if you've done basic high school
earth science no this is surprising
right that's how the whole planet works
and that's why i wanted to stop by here
that's why i wanted to show this to more
people
because my big question is is there
anything like this left anything that
can be explained in a couple of minutes
to a modern person that describes
something that's now obvious to pretty
much everyone
but that is still sitting undiscovered
somewhere out there in the world until
one person with the right knowledge is
in the right place i think it's unlikely
there's anything like that left with 8
billion people on the planet and
satellite photography of pretty much
every part of it i think it's probable
that we've got all the low hanging fruit
but wouldn't it be wonderful if for once
just for once
somewhere in the world
we got a new discovery like this
you